thank you very much charlie
and welcome everybody today we're going
to be talking about the applied
biosystems
magnamax core nucleic acid purification
kit
so i'm very excited to present to you
the newest
product from applied biosystems animal
health
sample preparation portfolio and the
magmax core product is
truly a unique concept when we
set out to develop this product we're
really looking at
four things to offer labs first
flexibility second familiarity
third a reduction in waste
and then finally an opportunity for labs
to develop
new testing applications and so
that's how we came up with the magmax
core
concept which at its base starts out
at a core chemical formulation
highly universal and flexible in nature
and then what we've done is added
application specific modules
that can be coupled with the core
chemistry to create
unique applications for labs to use
today
and in the future
so we talk about the value that magmax
core
nucleic acid purification kit brings to
the market
we like to say that magmax core has been
designed
for three purposes one to accelerate
two to optimize and three to evolve
when we talk about accelerate the value
that this product brings
to our customers is less preparation
time
faster nucleic acid extraction time
and a higher level of sensitivity and
what that means to you
is higher volume consistent quality rna
and dna
extracted material ready for your
testing environment
so when we talk about optimizing what
really trying to do is improve
efficiency
for your lab and one of the things we
looked at
is reducing overall waste and by
reducing the number of washes
in the chemical formulation of magmax
core we've
done two things one is we've eliminated
the amount of
reagents used for a particular
workflow and secondly by eliminating
wash steps
we've actually reduced the plastics used
with your nucleic acid purification
instrumentation
secondly we delivered products that are
able to be shipped
and stored at room temperature thereby
reducing
unnecessary cost and space associated
with refrigerators and freezers and then
lastly
we developed a truly universal solution
that can be used in a wide range of
applications
and on a wide range of animal types
and finally when we say that magmax
score
is designed to evolve what that means is
that it can actually
evolve with your testing needs a core
chemistry
that's highly universal that can grow
with your testing needs by adding
additional
nucleic acid purification modules means
that
magmax core could truly be the very last
sample preparation
product your lab may ever need
so additionally we spent significant
time
ensuring that magmax core nucleic acid
purification kit
really delivered in best-in-class
performance
and after months and months of design
and development
we were able to ensure that you the
customer will be able to achieve high
quality extractions
regardless of sample size
and in terms of the modules that are
available for magmax score
we currently have two different modules
first is our mastitis and pan bacteria
module
which can aid in the processing of
bacteria
especially those critical in mastitis
as well as challenging matrices like
acidic milk
and then secondly we've offered the
mechanical lysis module
which aids in the processing of hard to
lyse organisms such as
map and bovine tuberculosis
in feces milk as well as an
environmental samples
and these are just the first two modules
that we've developed
in the months and years to come there'll
be plenty more
offerings for magmax core
we also spent a good deal of time
focusing on the format
of the magmax core kit when we talk
about format we really looked at
three unique areas one were the
components themselves
secondly the technology and science
behind the formulation of the product
and finally
ergonomics and usability so in terms of
the components
we offer two different kit sizes one 100
reaction kit
and the other a 500 reaction kit we've
also
ensured that no additional alcohols need
to be needed
need to be used for this kit so all
washes
are pre-mixed with alcohol from a
technology standpoint
we spent years optimizing the magnetic
beads used in this kit
to ensure that you will have superior
bead performance
and in terms of the overall reagent
formulation itself
it's a compatible formulation that's not
only used in qpcr workflows
but it's also compatible in sequencing
applications as well
and then finally from an ergonomic
standpoint
we've ensured that the formulation can
be shipped and stored
at room temperature which adds
convenience
time and cost savings and we've reduced
the washes
to only two which eliminates unnecessary
reagents
as well as plastics
and in terms of the sample types that
are validated with this particular kit
at the time of development we were able
to optimize
the magmax core nucleic acid
purification kit
on more animal matrices than any other
kit on the market
which means that your lab has extreme
levels of
flexibility and regardless of what
sample type comes into your doors
you can feel confident that magmax core
is going to be able to provide you
the solution and performance that you
need
in terms of instrument workflows we've
developed four
optimized workflows to address all of
those sample types listed before
we have a simple workflow which is used
for liquid sample matrices that
require little processing steps
we have a digestion workflow which is
for sample matrices that require
pk digestion we have a complex workflow
which are for those matrices that
require a clarification step
and then finally we have a lysis
incubation workflow
for samples such as ear punches that
come in a lysis solution
in terms of instrumentation we ensured
that the product can be used on all
available
kingfisher nucleic acid purification
instrumentation including
the kingfisher flex the kickfisher duo
prime
the kingfisher ml and the magmax express
96
thereby giving labs flexibility and
ensuring that whatever instrument they
have in their lab
is going to be compatible with our
magmax core kits
and in order to minimize overall
instrument run time
we spend a good deal of time ensuring
that we optimize the on instrument
scripts
so there's actually two available
scripts on each one of the kingfisher
instrumentation we have a heated script
with a 27 minute runtime
and a non-heated script that offers a 36
minute runtime
as i said these are common scripts that
can be used across all kingfisher
instruments
and offering heated as well as
non-heated
options for labs
so in summary magmax core
is going to enable your lab to
accelerate
by offering faster and fewer steps
optimize by delivering a universal
sample prep
with less waste to evolve
by delivering one trusted chemistry that
can grow and expand with your testing
needs
to deliver high performance by offering
consistent
and high quality extracted nucleic acid
so i'll leave you today with ordering
information for all of our core kits and
modules
this includes the individual modules as
well as
combination kits and all ancillary and
additional products
that can help support the selected
workflow of your choice
thank you very much for your time it was
a pleasure speaking with you today
and if you have any questions or need
more information
please don't hesitate to visit the
animal health booth
i believe we have some time for
additional q a
so i'll hand it back to you charlie